it's been called the most infamous man
on the internet Andrew Tate is certainly
one of the most Googled people on the
planet this year more than 17 million
people watched his first interview on
this show and tonight he's back
Piers Morgan uncensored well good
evening Rolanda welcome to Piers Morgan
uncensored have you ever heard of Mr
Beast what about PewDiePie how about
keemstar Logan Paul Jake Paul the answer
might well be no you haven't heard of
them but if you've got kids
you will definitely have heard of them
and they most certainly have they're
just a tiny handful of the legions of
digital personalities whose videos are
viewed by literally billions of young
people across the world their
endorsements are worth millions in sales
their opinions can instantly reshape
conversations in schools universities
and across social media they're more
influence than most musicians soap stars
sports stars columnists lawmakers but
unlike those power Brokers of the past
the politicians and cultural stars who
can set the social agenda these people
seem to exist in a parallel universe
their views go largely unchallenged
shared only as bite-sized Clips they're
digital businesses often operate beyond
the scrutiny of normal journalism even
Regulators they will massive influence
over young people and they're restricted
only by the ever-changing whims of big
tech companies it makes no more sense
the senators or secretaries and state
simply never appearing on television
well my guest tonight is a perfect case
important example of both enormous Digi
digital conquest and the risks that come
with it is Andrew Tate his last
interview with me has so far been viewed
well over 8 million times on YouTube
Alone 17 million times across all
platforms which is staggering for
someone who perhaps you're watching and
thinking who is Andrew T
it was a robust Exchange
and Andrew had tape was here because it
effectively being kicked off the
mainstream internet for supposed
misogyny his terrains against women were
viewed literally billions of times well
the first time around I wanted to find
out if he deserved to be banned and if
he'd ever actually crossed a line from
shocking opinions to genuine hate speech
or if it just didn't fit the ideal model
of the platforms that censored him
let's go through some sure right do you
think women are the property of men no
the point why have you said they are
because I made a religious Point
Authority implies that you have the
ability to control someone now Authority
believes the authority implies I have
the moral right to sit and say that
that's an irresponsible thing to do and
I'm responsible that's not what
Authority means I don't interrupt you I
just want to point out that's not what
Authority means if someone gives you can
a person can give voluntary Authority is
not Authority no but that's the point
you could say I'm interrupting you do
but you're answering a different
question to the one I asked you fine no
the more weaponizing the weaponizing
that doesn't exist no problem if someone
comes to me and says I'm clinically
depressed or I feel very very sad I
would say the first thing you need to do
is stop accepting the identity of a
clinically depressed person stop
accepting you have no control over this
Andrew You're simply wrong
if that's what you believe peers it's
what I believe I don't believe in things
that take power away there is not an
eminent doctor in the world would agree
with this I think you know more than
doctors I can't become clinically
depressed
why do you know because I don't believe
it
it's a lively stuff I also wasn't sure
if I should be interviewing him at all
if he was so unpleasant as so many
people said but why extend his profile
and give him a platform but the fact is
that that ship had already sailed every
teenager in the country knows Andrew
Tate it's just a lot of the parents who
don't since that interview Andrew has
been returned to Twitter his new owner
Elon Musk is determined to perfect
Protect free speech online many young
people especially boys have literally
stopped me in the street since that
first interview to ask me about Andrew
Tate I've been staggered Honestly by the
response that I've had what does it say
about society that people like Andrew
take and reach so many more people than
conventional stars or journalists even
who gets to decide where the line is and
whether people like Andrew take cross it
are they part of a poorly understood
movement the pandas to teenage rebellion
like punk rock or pornography or are we
exposing young people to new and
damaging experiences we often don't see
and don't understand it's a whole new
world there are more questions about it
than answers I'm not going to answer
them by pretending it doesn't exist well
Andrew Tate joins me again now Andrew
good to see you salam alaikum peers good
to see you I I've genuinely been Amazed
by the reaction I've had in the streets
not just here but I went to Qatar for
the World Cup had the same thing there a
lot of people coming up about because
John Ronaldo obviously but also a lot of
people coming up about you and they were
almost exclusively men young men who
genuinely see you as a role model as
somebody who inspires them as somebody
they want to be like yeah so it made me
think the first interview you had was
quite combative the second time a short
interview less so I want to try and work
out in this one who you are because it
struck me as extraordinary that Google
this week revealed some stats for the
year the number one person whose name
followed people Google searching who is
in 2022 was Andrew Tate yeah that's
quite remarkable I think there's a whole
swath of the population especially young
men that feel disenfranchised they feel
disenfranchised with the media machine
and the things they're supposed to
believe they don't feel an affinity with
the Educational Systems or the culture
and they look at a person like me who
stands up and says the things that many
young men think I haven't put a magic
spell on the world the fact that people
like what I say means that they agree
with me deep inside they may be afraid
to say it themselves but I am seen as a
Bastion of free speech and a Bastion
Bastion from masculinity as a whole
because a lot of men are largely
forgotten about do you think you're a
Force for good or are you a force in
evolution
where perhaps you've done unsaid stuff
you shouldn't have done and as you get
older perhaps as you get bigger more
followed around the world you sense a
responsibility perhaps you didn't have
early on well we all evolve every human
evolves day by day you wouldn't be human
if you didn't evolve on an hour-by-hour
basis but I do not think I'm a Force for
good I absolutely not really know I am a
Force for good because I'm a force for
truth and truth is a good thing without
truth we're going to end up in absolute
tyranny in slavery and we're already on
our way there I feel like we're starting
to combat it my cancellation was the
beginning of a change in public
Consciousness Elon having Twitter is
another beginning of the change in
public Consciousness and anybody who
stands up and speaks what they truly
believe even if it's something I don't
personally agree with I think that truth
is absolutely important and people's
personal truths and people's personal
opinions even on differing sides of the
same opinion should be heard
tell me about your life you were born to
a mixed race uh couple your father was
an African-American a chess player and
your mother she was from this country
correct yeah so my father was was black
chess player he was in the Air Force he
met my mother here in England and then I
was raised initially in the United
States and then I moved to Luton England
when I was younger so I've moved around
a lot I've lived uh eclectic life in
many different scenarios we've moved
around I've done a lot of different
things lived a lot of different
experiences and uh well I mean would you
identify I consider myself British now
but I will say that part of me the
Patriotic Britain side of me is
devastated by the state of the UK
currently and I want to make that very
clear the Patriotic Britain me truly
loves this country and seeing what's
happening to it especially to our major
cities is almost heartbreaking to watch
in real time in what way it's falling
apart this is a failed Society by every
metric you can possibly measure it is
absolutely not really failing the cost
of living crisis the crime rates
everything is falling apart if you
compare it to a country tree like the
United Arab Emirates you compare it to a
city like Dubai London which should be
the greatest city on earth is failing in
absolutely every metric because our
leadership is a joke if you look at
Dubai in the UAE the leadership there is
so Flawless so genuinely genius they saw
ahead and built almost a Utopia and then
you look at London you can't walk around
with a watch on it's disgusting you know
it's very interesting I was in Qatar for
the World Cup obviously a lot of people
in England taking a very sensorious
moral view about the World Cup being in
the Middle East at all because of their
laws against homosexuality because of
their treatment of Migrant workers I've
got to say not that I don't share the
concerns about those things of course I
do but I found a lot of The Virtue
signaling and I think that's what it was
in many cases about the whole region
actually quite distasteful because when
I was in Qatar
a I thought the World Cup was
fantastically well run an incredibly
good experience but a lot of qataris
were saying to me you know there's this
weird quaint feeling back in your
country that we'll want to Aspire to
behave like that that we all want to
live in a country with massive drug
problems with massive knife crime issues
with scenes like the European
championships final where it's complete
lawlessness going on
um where
stuff like the NHS the system of
healthcare is basically collapsing where
the education system is dropping behind
so on and so on and so on it's a really
interesting perspective they were like I
know you all think that we want to have
your form of democracy in your form of
life but actually we're fine thanks
absolutely because it's a failed society
and it's Godless I think it's disgusting
we leave our old people to rot in old
people's homes and then we sit there and
say we don't have enough money for
nurses I understand this nurse strike
very well on how frustrating it can be
if you walk into a hospital and the
nurse is not prepared to work but the
nurses would be prepared to work at the
current wage if they believe this
country was spending his money prudently
when you see this country spending its
money and just absolutely wasting it
pulling out of thin air to fund proxy
wars God knows where that has nothing to
do with them of course as a nurse you're
going to stand up and say well can I get
a pay rise this country has failed on
every metric and especially our major
cities I've just come to London now I
made it very clear to my private jet
pilot I said fuel the Jet and leave it
running because the second I'm finished
talking appears I'm leaving this bit
it's disgusting this country and London
as a whole 10 years ago was one of the
most hospitable cities on Earth now you
cannot walk around safely with a watch
on and you're a full-grown man you're a
full-grown adult when's the last time
there's been a serious problem in your
life that you completely ignored and it
fixed itself never ever what are any of
our politicians doing to fix any of the
problems
planning to run again with a third term
of offices mayor all I can say is I just
everyone I know who's had any experience
of crime at any level in London in the
last few years has had a bad experience
of it of the way it's been handled you
know I mean I can give an example I can
reveal this now I've talked for 18
months I've got a specific death threat
on one of my son's Instagram pages in
public a public comment and it was very
specific about what this person was
going to do I couldn't use the police to
evade him we we know where you live
we're going to come and kill you and
then the second one threatening uh my
son and his mother my ex-wife I called
in the police I'm not having them
putting death threats on my sons I
called the police police investigated
this they arrested somebody over a year
ago and then I heard from the police
this week that despite 18 months of
Investigation of a publicly posted
comment on Instagram threatening to kill
me uh on my son's Instagram that they
will not be able to pursue the case now
I thought imagine I'm high profile this
was a front page of the Sun newspaper if
that same man called a transgender
person the wrong pronouns he would be in
trouble right so doesn't it just show
Absolutely how absolutely asinine and
banal our legal system has become that
would never happen in a country like you
never United Arab Emirates the place I'm
now residing in Dubai where the
leadership has common sense and I'm
saying that all the leadership
structures doesn't matter if labor or
conservative across all of it in this
nation of completely he failed Sadiq
Khan is a loser because when you have a
city which is losing which London is is
losing and all very in all metrics
across its competitive cities around the
world and you're in charge of it by
extension you're a loser I will tell you
right now instead of virtue signaling
and giving Qatar a hard time over their
religious beliefs what we should be
doing is a treaty with Qatar to build a
prison deep in the desert give me make
me mayor of London we'll make a prison
deep in the desert and if you're caught
with a knife or robbing someone you can
go do 25 years with one meal a day in
the in the scorching sun and then what
we'll do is we'll put cameras there and
we'll interview you once a week and
broadcast that out to the nation and see
if you change your mind and make people
understand that this is a country that
should be respected and our law should
be respected instead what happens what a
city or any of the people in charge of
this country actually done to fix any of
our issues besides sit around and talk
nothing none of them have done anything
but they seem Ultra concerned with
finding money for proxy wars Ultra
concerned with rainbow Flags in another
country that is uninterested in them and
their priorities are completely messed
up of course the ambulance people are of
course the ambulance drivers are
striking of course the nurses are
striking nobody cares about the most
important things in this nation it's a
failing country in real time and that's
why I've left what about the specific
allegation by the way I don't disagree
with a lot of that um because I do think
this country is in big trouble and I do
think that one of the problems is people
think if they do have a crime against
them nobody cares anymore I know I know
nobody cares I can I have specific
examples and people who I know
personally absolutely and utterly nobody
cares I was in herod's yesterday and
someone tried to Rob someone's watch in
the middle of the store I walk around
with six full growth I have a security
team of six full-grown men plus me and
my brother eight military age males all
over 110 kilos big men just so I can
walk around this city it's absolutely
unacceptable
what about the issue of race and I
mentioned that in the context of the
Harry and Megan ongoing debate their war
with the royal family war against the
monarchy their specific uh constant uh
referencing to the fact that they
believe they were driven out of here
because of racism in Britain what do you
make of that debate that that's absolute
fallacy and you're from a mixed race
correct background yourself correct I'm
from a mixed race background myself and
while we're discussing the leaders of
the UK although I do think they're doing
a terrible job it's kind of hard for
Megan to say that the UK is a racist
country when the leader of the UK is
darker skinned than her and the mayor of
London is darker skinned than her and I
am a person who's probably darker
skinned than her and I've never
experienced any kind of bigotry against
myself besides the fact I'm a straight
male I'll get bigotry for that before
I'll get bigotry for my skin color I
think it's just a cop out in her not
wanting to be perspicacious and
self-reflective enough to understand
that she has attacked an age-old
institution and there are people who are
very patriotic about that institution
and by attacking it and bringing a
degree of distaste to it there's going
to be don't like her and if you're a
dislikable person you can't just
instantly stand up and say it's because
of my skin color it might because be
because of your actions and some of the
things you've said I mean I think
there's probably no doubt she said
racism on social media because who
hasn't it's a system you probably have
well as I said yourself I've had death
threats on social media no no one seemed
to care very much um but I I think
that's probably inarguable my issue with
what they've both been doing is if
you're going to make allegations against
an institution like they're all family
and the monarchy you've got to actually
provide some evidence you can't just
spray gun this thing out there and say
well somebody was racist yeah and airing
dirty laundry is never going to be
respected by the populace and being a
tattletail is never going to be
respected by the populace and I think
the problem with the modern world we're
living in is a lot of age-old traditions
are being destroyed in real time it
doesn't matter what the tradition is
most of them are being eroded and
something like the British royal family
which has been around for a very long
time is an age-old tradition one of the
things holding the UK together one of
the last things we have to sit and
detriment it and to sit and insult it
and to give way secrets from inside of
it and try and paint a negative image of
it is going to upset a lot of people and
you have to be prepared for that
backlash you can't say I've done things
to upset people but it's nothing to do
with what I've done it's purely because
of my skin color also it's kind of
ironic that she's doing that because
she's not particularly dark skinned it's
kind of funny to sit her sit here sick I
mean
I think the truth is I don't know what
look you can say that I can't
um the reality of it is I just don't
know what the specifics of the racism
she says she's had because we've not
seen any evidence the universe is a
funny Place Pierce if you're looking for
something you're gonna find it right
when I got canceled when they attacked
me unfairly lied about me across the
entire mainstream media deleted me from
social media so I couldn't defend myself
and lied about me repeatedly I could
have stood up and said it's because I'm
Brown I didn't do that I sat and said
okay there's people who misunderstand my
message my message is is a positive one
people misunderstand me let me
self-reflect and understand that yes
perhaps this said a long time ago was
said in the wrong way perhaps this was
understood perhaps people don't
understand this I could have just copped
out and could have just been refusing to
self-reflect on any level and said it's
because I'm Brown that's why they did it
but that's not the immature way to be as
an adult what did you think of the
Jeremy Clarkson Fury where he wrote well
I think most people but including him
belatedly after he'd published it and
written the column he did make an
analogy from A Game of Thrones uh scene
which most people I think did find
across the line and was deeply offensive
I I think you've crossed a line what do
you think yeah I understand why people
feel that but when you attack an
institution as old as the British royal
family you're attacking patriotism in
and of itself for one of the
most respected countries or previously
most respected countries on Earth and
you're going to have some visceral
reactions perhaps Jeremy Clarkson is too
famous and too well renowned to say
those kind of things but there's a lot
of people who genuinely feel that way
and that's why he said it and this is
what happens when you attack age-old
institutions on any country should he
ever apologize that's a good question it
looks like he did personally I think as
a man you should stand up say what you
mean mean what you say I don't think you
should ever apologize for anything
you've ever said even me what if you say
something truly then if you're very
offensive and you actually do regret it
if you truly regret it then yeah okay
you can apologize but if at the time you
meant it then the best thing you can do
is say look I have just changed my mind
I no longer feel that way but at the
time that's how I felt and I'm the
person who says what he feels and that's
what I felt at the time and I apologize
that offended you as you say we'll be
back with you after the break we'll talk
to you about Twitter again uh Elon Musk
retort restoring users platform has it
calmed you down are you as controversial
on there are you mindful that you're
only one false move like Kanye West for
example away from being removed again
we'll talk about after the break
[Music]
what Elon Musk has restored a stronger
band accounts as taking over Twitter
with a small commitment to free speech
it's also shown he has a line of his own
though conspiracy theorist Alex Jones
remains banned Kanye yay West was
reinstated then banned again for posting
a swastika inside the Star of David
Andrew Tate is back two for now anyway
he was first removed in 2017 for saying
women should bear some responsibilities
victims of rape and he hasn't exactly
been shy since his reprieve let's take a
look
Genghis Khan had endless women and 200
children as a reward for Conquest he
tweeted on the most searched man on the
planet I've conquered Earth on the
highest status male on the planet
females do not expect loyalty from me
they only expect that of lesser men
then there was this imagine having less
than 10 children because you're eight
who doesn't have four wives genetic
failures finally if a girl follows me
and she's hot and I see a single picture
of it a private jet it's block women
can't afford Jets women are all brokies
why are you flying around on sunland's
jet you should have been a virgin when I
met you Haram all right Angie Tate now
you're you're getting very near the
knuckle with some of those tweets am I
you tell me I don't think so I think
people can understand they're
semi-satirical I think people can
understand you mean them as jokes or do
you mean them it's not that I don't mean
them as jokes I mean they're a overall
public commentary and observation I do
mean what I say if I were to see a girl
on a private plane on Instagram for
example I would assume that a man put
her on that private plane I would not
assume she bought it herself well if it
was perhaps that makes me misogynistic
what if it was Ariana Grande or Beyonce
well that's slightly different isn't it
why because they're famous yeah of
course and they're famous and very rich
if I saw well if I saw a 19 year old
girl from Moldova where the average
wages 200 a month and she was on a
private jet I would assume that with the
balance of probabilities considering I'm
an adult it's very likely because of her
beauty a man has put her on that private
plane yes if that makes me misogynistic
instead of just perspicacious enough to
understand how the world works so be it
I'm a realist should you be such a
generalist about these things well you
have to be a generalist when you're
looking for in the balance of
probabilities and trying to find balance
in the world you have to be a generalist
in general if I stroke a lion it's gonna
bite my hand in general there might be a
nice one but I don't want to find out so
that's how the world Works you've
praised the Taliban in the past would
you do so again tonight the world is not
black and white the world is gray it's
very difficult to sit and make black and
white assumptions about anything to sit
and say that the Taliban are completely
inertly evil and we're completely
inertly good as you just discussed with
the moral High Ground I believe that the
Taliban bring law and order it may not
be the Law and Order we like but it's a
form of Law and Order and humans try
usually gravitate what about their
treatment than women only tonight only
tonight they have banned any women from
going to University
fantastic let's get the feminists to go
and teach them a lesson the feminists
are so tough and they stand up and say
they can do anything a man can do let's
arm them up and send them to Afghanistan
I'm sure it'll fix it yeah but it's it's
not it's a it's a serious matter isn't
it that women don't that's the education
and that's a very serious answer if
women are just as capable as men in
terms of combat like feminists pretend
they are they can go over there and they
can deal with it a lot of women do go to
combat well exactly so they can go deal
the talibans nothing to do with me they
can stand up and fight for their own
right surely you wouldn't defend the
Taliban Banning women from universities
saying has nothing to do with me Pierce
it's absolutely nothing what about the
Afghan women it's nothing to do with me
on any level you don't have a view I
have a view my view is that people
naturally gravitate towards Law and
Order and if you didn't have the Taliban
you'd have different Warlords operating
in lawlessness and there would be no way
to prevent your store your Market stall
getting completely robbed by someone
with an AK-47 and people are going to
gravitate towards a form of Law and
Order America left they left a power
vacuum and the power vacuum is now full
I don't disagree with that okay well I
do think I do think the Banning of
Women's University in Afghanistan is
utterly horrific and I think the
feminists are going to arm themselves
they're going to show us that they can
do anything a man can do they're going
to go over there to combat they're going
to teach child of adolescents why can't
you just say on that you know what is
completely wrong because it's not my
point it's I don't understand it makes
me think it'll make your critics think
that you don't think it's wrong they
could ban all men they could ban all
shorts but they're not they're only
Banning women correct they could ban all
short people they could ban all people
with long hair and not if it's anything
to do with me so they can do whatever
they want I'm not going to go to war
with the Taliban but you've just
literally spent an impassioned first
segment comparing the way for example
Dubai handles Law and Order correct to
this country correct so you do Express
views about different laws absolutely
both places so when I put to a law that
basically bans women from being educated
it's not why is it a problem for you to
say you know what it's wrong there are
both places I've resided in to buy
London so I have personal experience I
can give my personal opinion but like I
said there's absolutely nothing to do
with me with what the Taliban decide to
do inside of Afghanistan and they decide
that's the most prudent way to run their
society then we have two choices we can
either go over there and start another
war that we shouldn't be involved in and
waste a bunch of life or we can sit and
say it's up to them they should govern
themselves their people we're no better
than them and they've decided to live
their lives a particular way and that's
how they're going to live it like I said
if feminists are very upset and they're
very disgusted by the fact that in
Afghanistan women cannot go to school
I've been told repeatedly by feminists
that they're just capable as men in all
Realms and I expect them to arm
themselves and fly over to Afghanistan
and fix it like a lot of women have done
in combat I'm good congratulations go
fight
well this is the thing that's very
interesting because when you talk about
ideas it's not even just about
Afghanistan and feminism you talk about
ideas they must all be defended at some
point there has to come down to violence
the world is backed by violence nobody
wants to talk about this it doesn't
matter what it is if you have a
disagreement between two parties
eventually if the disagreement continues
it ends up in violence feminism is
defended by men men stand up and defend
feminism not feminists themselves
because they're incapable of violence
and we're in a situation now where
you're saying that we should send men to
go and fight for feminism why it's not a
man's problem
I think well hey I think men can be
feminist too because if feminism
believes in equality for women
I don't agree with radical feminists who
hate men right do to me the radical
anything to me is a bad thing yeah and I
think most feminism in the west
currently is radical
well some of it is no question
absolutely but that's my point my point
is that with the Taliban are going to do
whatever the Taliban decide to do if I'm
going to fly over to another country I
will respect their laws and customs it's
not my job to come along and tell other
people how to live I don't believe I
have a moral High Ground in that degree
and if people are genuinely upset and
disgusted by it the bottom line and most
disagreements from the earth is violence
people who feel like they should go and
fix it then fix it with violence then it
can be the feminists who feel so
outraged by it but it's funny they don't
comment on these subjects feminists they
seem to instead attack the Western male
for some reason you've deleted a video
in which you praised Isis why I don't
know which video you're talking about in
particular it might have been a video
from a long time ago but in general I
understand that like I said the world is
not black and white the world is gray
areas and Western imperialism as a whole
has been causing more problems than it's
ever fixed and it's disgusting and I
don't know the exact video You're
referencing but sometimes when an
underdog destroys a western imperialist
I have a degree of
I wouldn't say satisfaction but every
satisfaction no but there's there's
certainly a degree of oh the way Isis I
don't know the particular themselves I
don't know about the particular video
we're talking Isis were one of the most
deadly Terror groups in the world
absolutely they committed a series of
appalling atrocities sure killing
innocent people left right in the center
yeah how could you possibly have
satisfaction well if it's the video I'm
recollecting if it's the video we're
talking about it's about the fact that I
believe Isis was funded by the west and
create by the West in the first place
and it wasn't a degree of satisfaction
like I'm happy Isis exists it was a
commentary on the world well here's what
you said Isis are the real Muslims
because I assist exactly what the book
says kill everyone is not a Muslim and
chop people's heads off and set them on
fire and be raging lunatics but all the
other Muslims go they're not real
Muslims because I read the book and
ignore those parts well then you're not
an effing Muslim because you're ignoring
the effing book
that's an interesting that's an
interesting point you've just raised
because I am now Islamic and it's it's
funny because I used to be an atheist
and when you're an atheist you believe
that religion causes more problems than
it fixes and then you come to a
realization and you start to learn the
truth of yourself and the truth of God
and you realize that religion is
actually the cure for most of the
problems in the world and godlessness is
the problem in the world so that is
something I will apologize for admit I
was wrong about because I was atheistic
and now as a Muslim I understand that's
absolutely not the case if that's a
particular video you're talking about
then then well that's really interesting
so you you regret saying that yeah
because you learn and you grow and you
evolve as I said at the time I believed
it because I didn't believe in God at
the time it was a very long time ago
it's actually kind of a testament to you
peers you manage to find the oldest
possible videos of me that have ever
existed but at the time I was atheistic
well no I was curious because you have
recently converted to Islam correct so
these questions are thinking pertinent
to your conversion absolutely as to what
you actually believe as a practicing
Muslim now uh yeah I believe that Islam
is beautiful I believe it's the last
True Religion on Earth it's certainly
the last respected religion on Earth and
I felt differently inside since I've
converted and I think it has the
solutions to a lot of the problems we're
facing in the world today
that particular video was once again
satirical a lot of people watching this
would not have seen it they would not
seen the joke element of it it's fine it
but it's not funny no well you know it's
like most of the time as we discussed in
our first interview with me things are
taken out of context short form etc etc
but
all in all you could say the same things
about Christians if you were to read the
Old Testament and say stick to the Old
Testament you'd kill anyone who works on
a Sunday so it's not applicable to you
women's countenance violence say again
you don't countenance violence I
absolutely do not countenance violence
when I was talking about violence being
the bottom line salute the bottom line
decider between
disagreeing points of view it's not I'm
calling for violence I'm just making a
commentary on how the world genuinely
functions but when you use the word like
satisfaction
you understand that people will watch
that and think how can you possibly find
any form of terrorism satisfying I don't
find any form of terrorism satisfying I
don't find Western terrorism satisfying
either I don't think it's satisfying
that we managed to find five hundred
thousand dollars per bomb to drop on
some farmer who makes four dollars a day
under the name of freedom and and we
can't seem to pay our nurses enough to
do their jobs I don't find any kind of
terrorism and it's actually very
interesting you talk about the world
terrorism terrorist and freedom fighter
good guy and bad guy all of this is
subjective there are people who believe
that the west of the biggest terrorists
on the Earth are people who believe that
America causes more Wars than anyone
else and they've killed more people than
anyone else and there's people who
believe the absolute opposite so once
again it depends who you're talking to
is the subjective conversation there's
no black and white in the world there's
areas of gray and that's how it is so I
thought you were talking about another
video where I was saying that Isis is
standing up and fighting for what they
believe in I'm not saying what they
believe in is right but that's what they
were fighting for at the time and it was
a completely different video than the
one you were actually referencing but
you would condemn them now I don't
condemn anybody doing anything bad to
anybody I I'm not a person out here with
a criminal record I don't hurt anyone I
just spent my first
segment on this show talking about how I
believe in Law and Order and how
important that is I think people can
operate inside of their lives safely and
walk around man woman child can walk
around in safety in any City they live
in how that Law and Order is constructed
is not my
jurisdiction I'm not in charge of the
Law and Order of of Afghanistan
Tajikistan Kyrgyzstan Afghanistan
Kazakhstan any of them there's nothing
to do with me I want to talk to you
after the break about masculinity why is
it that so many young men gravitate to
you what is your view of what it takes
to be a man what would Andrew say after
the break
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the special edition of
Piers Morgan uncension with Andrew Tate
one on one so Ash sarkar who's a lively
contributor to this program has tweeted
Andrew take or you're interviewing about
Free Speech thinks women are a man's
property we shouldn't be allowed to
drive both about only dating teenagers
to imprint on the misogynists are
discussing whether they're an
Afghanistan or a Swanky London Studio
am I a misogynist am I I don't think I
the first thing to think she said I
don't even truly believe it's I can if
you're prepared to listen to me I'll
explain to you exactly why she's not
really completely utterly wrong if you
can go through the points again do you
think you're a misogynist absolutely not
I'm not a misogynist on any level this
is one of those buzzwords they throw it
they just throw at people randomly
homophobic racist misogynistics throw it
out at people what is your view of women
I'm a realist what was your real view of
women I absolutely not only love women I
adore women I have good relationships
with women not a single woman has come
up to me on the street since I've been
canceled not a single one has said
anything negative every single one of
them has said positive things you're a
traditional male I wish more men were
like you you understand your masculine
roles you understand what you're
supposed to do you understand you're
supposed to protect women you're exactly
the kind of man I've been looking for
I've never had a negative interaction
with a female ever since I've been
dubbed the biggest massages where is the
please please let me finish I'm sorry
sorry Pierce also there's not been a
single woman who's accused me of a crime
not single woman is accused me of rape
not single woman's come out and said
anything from my entire past of 36 years
I've done anything wrong ever anybody
else with my level of Fame any football
or any other movie star at least has
people who've come out and accuse him of
rape XYZ I have no woman who's come out
and ever said I've hurt her no woman has
come out and ever said I've done damage
to her or been horrible to her everybody
who ever interacted with me has said
I've been a nice person all of them so
this random Twitter nobody who seems to
know so much is full of all right you've
responded to her Twain yeah where is the
line for you between masculinity which I
will always defend and which I agree
with I think a lot of women like men to
be masculine and and what has become
known as toxic masculinity and the
reason I ask you is that you are engaged
in that debate with men all the time
where is the line for you where men
shouldn't cross where the behavior
should be kept within a line please
define toxic masculinity well you tell
me what you think it crosses a line from
being a masculine good man to a bad man
there's no such thing as too much
masculinity if it's genuinely masculine
genuine masculinity is not out here to
hurt people's absolutely the opposite
it's out here to protect and when bad
things happen they call traditionally
masculine men if you need a firefighter
you need a masculine man when you call
the police because of the problem you
had you want masculine men and as soon
as a woman or a man is in trouble when
you look for backup you look for
masculine men and masculine men have a
duty to provide and protect those they
care about we have a duty to do things
we don't feel like doing because we know
we're supposed to do them and that's why
we stayed in the Titanic and died those
were masculine where did you get your
views about this from because what I
grew up with is the family I grew up
around and the father your mother yeah
and the world I lived in and I think a
lot of the things I'm saying now about
masculinity and how people should act in
the world how the world should function
we're considered completely normal and
accepted by everybody only 20 years ago
I think the world's just lost its mind
for me to stand up and say a man should
protect a woman now gets to be called a
misogynist and canceled if I said that
10 years ago I would say duh and what's
funny is everyone who argues against me
it says men shouldn't protect women
especially all the feminists if they
were with their boyfriend the man broke
into their house guess who they'd expect
to go downstairs
who do you think think they go
themselves are they going to Afghanistan
no we send men to do these things women
we send women in the armed forces too
but you have to generalize when you make
points there are many many exceptions
exceptions do not disprove the rule no
but they're you've got to concede there
are many courageous women serving in the
arms absolutely and utterly completely
correct but by and large traditionally
soldiers are men exceptions do not
disprove the rule
well it's not an exception it's the fact
that there are a lot of women on the
Armed Forces correct but if you were to
take the average Soldier they are a male
if you're allowed to say who's a male
and who isn't nowadays I'm assuming
their gender I apologize if you ever
take the average Soldier they're a male
which means that exceptions are the
female soldiers which because there's a
lower percent of them a lower
probability exceptions do not disprove
the rules men do the fight right now in
Ukraine men cannot leave women are
allowed to leave because men have to
fight in the front line and women are
allowed to go to Dubai that is how it is
what do you say to young men who come to
you for advice you feel lost you don't
really know where they fit into society
I say that life as a man is
exceptionally difficult I say the most
beautiful and the most terrifying thing
about being a manager born without value
Society doesn't care about you you're
only going to be cared about based on
how useful you are you have the chance
to build yourself up and become a
superhero if you're prepared to do the
hard work and be indefeatable enough to
never quit but if you're going to stand
around and wait for a handout nobody's
going to ever respect you and I think
that a lot of people have forgotten
about how difficult and how competitive
it is as a man always in constant
competition with each other and it's
your duty as a man to stand up and say I
want to be as important and strong and
good-hearted and God-fearing as possible
and I need to work hard to achieve those
things David Sheila Hancock says we've
become too over emotional as a society
crying too much about everything yes you
got a point she's completely right and
the dangerous thing about overly
emotional men is that they're dangerous
they're genuinely dangerous this is
what's crazy all these people who talk
about toxic masculinity and how bad it
is for men to be traditionally masculine
a traditionally masculine man does
things he doesn't feel like doing but
because it is his duty to do them he
charges into the burning building
because it is his duty not because he
feels like it because it is his duty
we're now teaching the new generation of
men that they don't have duty and they
can just act on their feelings and act
how they feel and they don't have to act
as a man should do you know what happens
when you get men who just act how they
feel you get School shooters you get
violence you get rapists men who do not
control their emotions are dangerous if
you find a man who is stoic he's not
going to hurt people he's going to sit
and think about his actions very
carefully and he's going to be a good
man who protects for it and provides for
his family you find a man who just acts
out on impulse and does whatever he
feels like you're going to find a
dangerous man sitting here telling men
to cry more and act with their feelings
and it's okay to feel this way that way
Etc and have no self-control that is why
we have the problems we have in the
world absolutely not only wrong so when
they talk about toxic masculinity they
have it completely inversed on its head
completely nutly wrong we need to be
teaching stoicism we need to be teaching
young men to understand that the world
is very very difficult it's hard to be a
man you're going to feel bad sometimes
you just suck it up and perform anyway
not to sit there and cry your eyes out
or blame other people
certainly talk off being a woman but I'm
not a woman so why would I speak on
issues I do not understand I'm a man you
can feel an empathy for women I feel
empathy certainly but I do not
understand their issues a lot of men
come up to me and they admire you I've
got to say a lot of women I've spoken to
don't admire they think you represent
misogyny they think when they hear you
not commit to saying the Taliban
shouldn't be banning women from
University education why can't he just
say that's wrong well firstly that's not
my experience I experience the absolute
and utter opposite of that secondly it's
because it's a moral point I'm making my
moral point is I speak on things I
understand I speak on experiences I've
had would you believe in equality I
speak yes sure I speak on subjects I
know intimately I do not feel qualified
I'm a realist and I do not feel
qualified to sit and discuss the gender
laws in Afghanistan I have not been to
Afghanistan I have not researched the
subject thoroughly I'm not going to sit
here and say how their Taliban should be
running their country it's nothing to do
with me I find it quite flattering peers
that although you know I understand I'm
monumentally influential the most Google
man on Earth Etc I find it very
flattering that you think I have some
kind of control over the domestic policy
of Afghanistan but I assure you I don't
I don't no no there's nothing to do I'm
not asking you to have a view on having
influence of a domestic policy I'm sure
the Taliban couldn't give us stuff what
I'd say about it um it's just curious to
me that it's an easy win for you to make
women think you're not answering them to
say that when they're not given a
quality as a woman in Afghanistan
clearly or not because they are not
allowed to go to university now as of
today that is clearly unequal unfair we
should all be able to agree that that is
wrong well certainly even you tough guy
Andrew not tough guy I am a professional
as a professional I can state that yes
it is not equal yes it is not fair that
is obvious for anybody I'm not saying
those things are not true what I'm
saying is it's nothing to do with me
right okay but you've made a concession
you think is wrong it's wrong I said
it's unequal and it's unfair yeah so
wrong well perhaps and force yourself
Andrew no perhaps it's wrong under
certain moral guidelines but under the
moral guidelines which are currently in
charge of the jurisdiction of
Afghanistan they don't believe it's
wrong it's nothing to do with me well
then I'm not going to sit here until
other countries how to run their laws
I'm going to live in societies
you know what I'll take unfair and
unequal sure because that's
self-explanatory we're gonna have a game
of chess in a minute after the break
because you are a very good chess player
I can hold my own in the chessboard your
father was a chess uh International
Master uh in fact and we're gonna
five-minute game of speed chess when it
takes all Mr Tate after the break me and
Andrew take live chess let's see he's
got the bigger brain shall we
[Music]
welcome back to Pennsylvania Tate is
still here Andrew's father was an
American chess International master and
his son's pretty good at it too well I
can hold my own that's my school chess
champion and with five minutes left on
the program we're gonna have a game of
speed chess when it takes all all right
we're all white off you go
that's racist peers cancel Piers Morgan
okay
are you good Pierce well you're gonna
destroy me clearly from this opening
better than you
uh okay let's be aggressive shall we
School chess champion eh
tense
certainly Lennox Lewis was better than
you when I played him was he well he
beat me 39 times out of 40 check yeah he
is uh pretty good at the game I heard
time to get aggressive with you Mr Tate
show you a bit of toxic chest
masculinity well
the world's been pretty aggressive with
me lately Pierce so uh I'm used to it
it's fine
okay
oops apologize
why do you think the queen for a 45 why
do you think the queen gets to jump
across the board and the King doesn't
because he's sexist
the game of chess is sexist but perhaps
it reflects life peers have you ever
thought that when you look at a yacht in
Dubai you're running out of time stop
stalling oh God I'll stick your queen
damn it I was trying to give you a
little speech there you didn't want to
listen to it when you see a yacht in
Dubai the girl just gets an Instagram
invite gets to jump right on board run
across the board and do whatever she
wants but the man is to get there a
square a Time the man had to buy that
yacht that's the difference between
being a man and being a woman that's why
the queen you know what she does a
chivalrous man just always lets ladies
go first life and chest just want to let
you go first life and chess reflect
peers
I've met a catastrophic error but I'm
bouncing back
see
I always accidentally take someone's
check three minutes I don't even mean to
it's just like oops
didn't even stop knocking my pieces over
like some
dog yeah exactly
it's not getting in my head
they're talking to me saying you're
getting in my head
um
how do you think chess reflects life I
think that it's all about strategy
correct that if you're good at chess you
can be good at pretty much anything
because it's about thinking ahead it's
about planning it's about Relentless
practice and you know what else is
beautiful about chess if you lose
somewhere you made a mistake there is no
luck absolutely right and chess even if
it's the smallest mistake somewhere it
was your fault it teaches absolute
self-accountability which is something
that we need a lot more of in the world
today no it's true and that's why chess
is so important you can take my knight
if you want you don't want it
uh because I'm playing a long game okay
I thought you'd want it I'm gonna leave
it there in case you take it anyway okay
I'm gonna go because I know what you
want me to do I'm not gonna do it
actually I will do it now okay good
check
uh exactly
check
check
how long I need to buy some time here
I need to buy some time
uh
this is really playing well on Radio by
the way
Dynamics
I'm screwed
I'm screwed
I will say that how long have I got one
minute believe in yourself I never ever
give up believe in yourself I do believe
myself thank you good self-belief is
important I do believe myself but this
has not gone well you're quite good at
chess I'll give you that
well in the chess board of life I've
done pretty good
I've done okay
check the question is can you beat me in
time you've only got 50 seconds check
that's interesting yeah I don't think
you can let's see uh
mating two piers
yeah you can have that doesn't matter
it's mating two check
mate goodbye
good game sir well played thank you 25
seconds away from safety
okay well as you say I'll give you
something uh you get a chess thank you
you have to be you just beat me
I know you're a national internationally
related what does chess talk to you
about life quickly I can teach you a lot
of things like I said about the queen
being able to run around the board the
king having to move a square at a time
about the fact you need to think ahead
absolutely everything is your fault but
there is a saying which is actually one
of my favorite sayings in the world that
said a well-gamed a well-played game of
chess is a sign of a gentleman but an
expertly game expertly played game of
chesses to sign up a wasted life and
it's kind of sad I put the links Lewis
in on somebody Apprentice 39 times out
of 40 in America years ago and he he
beat me 39 times out of 40 I mean uh and
I was amazed he was taught by his mum
but he was all about the way he fought
the way he boxed was all down to the way
he played chess yeah it was all about
looking ahead getting ahead of your
opponent planning planning punches you
know all that kind of thing just
absolutely reflects life and even I say
this now in my business meetings with my
team a lot of the problem in the world
today especially with teams and
businesses Etc everyone wants to be the
king but if you want to have a team if
you want to have a side that wins if you
want to win a game of chess everybody
has to know their role and do their role
effectively there can be a king and a
rook and a pawn and a bishop up in a
night and everyone does everything
correctly and when that happens you have
a very formidable board and you're hard
to be and uh chest reflects life
absolutely is something I do every
single day what kind of man was your
father
he was the greatest man on the face of
the planet but uh luckily he had me and
now in the natural order of the universe
he is gone and I am here and I carry his
name and it is my duty to bring honor to
him and this is one of the greatest
things about achievement because
achievement honors your ancestors people
talk about my father because of how
successful I am and people will talk
about me into eternity even after my
death because of how successful uh my
son will be this is the great thing
about achievement it's an honor to your
ancestors what would you have made of
your success your father he would be
extremely
underwhelmed by it because he always
expected it of me I am Emory Andrew take
the third I can do whatever I put my
mind to and he would be like well of
course you decided you want to become
the most famous man on the planet it
took you a few months of course does
your does your mother ever do what my
mother does and occasionally go I think
you went too farther my mother has
absolute trust in my abilities and
capabilities she says be careful do your
best but you are the most capable and
competent man on the planet that wasn't
the question that that's what she says
she says be careful does she ever say
you shouldn't have said that nah she
knows better than that really come now
never she says you're just be careful
you know what you're doing it's kind of
hard to argue against me and this is
what my haters seem to struggle with
it's hard to argue against the person
who is monumentally successful in every
single human metric that can possibly be
measured this is why young men respect
me so much would you ever tell your
mother they want to be my life you ever
tell her what to do I don't need to
she's a full grown woman would you ever
tell her what to do I would give her my
advice if she asked first you say you
can't leave the home you can't drive all
those things you joke about I would give
her my I'd give her my opinion I would
say perhaps you should move house now or
perhaps that's not safe or yeah I would
absolutely because I'm responsible for
her safety and when you're responsible
for somebody's safety you have an
opinion and you need to have a firm
opinion on that subject so completely
for any woman I am responsible for for
any woman I'm responsible for her safety
I will sit and say that's an unsafe
thing to do how much are you worth
I'm a billionaire by now dollars or
pounds about dollars we're not in pounds
yeah but we'll get there so what to do
yeah we have a little bit of work to do
but finally I know you don't know
anything about football and carry the
list but greatest of all time Ronaldo
and Messi they're both two very
hard-working men I have absolute respect
for anybody on Earth who dedicates
himself
Andrew Tate thank you very much indeed
that's it for tonight keep it
unsensitive like it was tonight good
night
[Music]